grando pays vous propose cette semaine
une randonnée dans l'enclos du volcan
vers le piton kapor rendez vous au
volcan sur le parking du pas de
bellecombe
nous y retrouvons lors et un beau joe du
parc national depuis le point de vue du
pas de bellecombe
on peut observer notre objectif du jour
le piton kapor situé juste à gauche du
volcan dans le prolongement de la pente
on va
non
le pas de bellecombe et le site de
montagne le plus fréquentées de l'île et
ça se voit ce jour-là il y a tellement
de monde que la descente vers l'enclos
pourrait ressembler aux marches de la
tour eiffel au pied du rempart le
sentier par tout de suite sur la gauche
sans passer devant le formica leo très
bien balisé de marque blanche
il nous emmène en plein coeur de
l'enclos pour une traversée en toute
sécurité
l'occasion de découvrir des plantes qui
vivent ici sur cette première petit
sentier on retrouve une végétation qui
est typique de des milieux d'altitude de
la réunion et notamment du piton de la
fournaise est et on s'aperçoit qui si
elle est très clairsemé très rasé en
fait c'est dû en fait tout simplement
aux conditions qui sont très difficiles
il ya très peu de soles il peut faire
très froid l'enseignement comme
aujourd'hui peut être très fort et en
fait ya deux raisons qui permettent
quand même l'installation d'une
végétation comme on voit aujourd'hui
c'est que à la fois on a le rang parqués
derrière qui lui est très végétalisée
donc qui apporte une grande partie de
semences est à la fois la présence de
fissures comme on voit ici on envoie un
petit peu partout en fait dans ses
fiches sur les plans dont pour être à
l'abri notamment du vent et c'est des
zones où le sol et d'humus va pouvoir
s'accumuler et qui ont permis le
développement de nombreuses espèces et
notamment lamballe gilles blanc qui j'en
parle aujourd'hui parce que cette saison
il en fleurs il fait d'être belle
attributs floraison jaune
après un petit kilomètre depuis le pied
du rempart on atteint une récente coulé
en gratton issu de l'éruption du piton
célimène en 2000 changement de décor et
d'ambiance garantis et forcément la
végétation qui recolonise la coulée
n'est pas la même que celle que l'on
vient d'observer la scène colloque est
très récente donc du coup on va vraiment
les premiers stades d'installation de la
flore en fait sur c'est sur ces coulées
basaltiques
on a à la fois le tout premier stade
c'est l'installation du lichen donc
c'est un lichen blanc qui s'appelle
stéréo que l'on vulcaniques donc c'est
vraiment un week-end qui a adapté à la
colonisation des coulées de lave donc
c'est lui qui va arriver en premier qui
va commencer à former un petit peu
d'humus un petit peu de soles et une
fois que qu'il y aura suffisamment de
d'humus pour l'installation pour son
installation va avoir l'apparition de
certaines fougères et notamment celle ci
qui est un bloc notes à bülach est alors
t'as bu leur est pas ce qu il peut
former des comme une sorte de petit rond
qui peuvent être assez haut et donc là
on revient à ce qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure on voit que malgré tout il
s'installe dans les endroits qui sont
plus à l'abri donc dans des fissures
votre hâle à avoir des conditions des
conditions climatiques
arrivé au piton kapor le sentier ne
permet pas de le gravir mais nous emmène
un peu plus haut pour profiter du
panorama
depuis le point de vue on observe
aisément ce python qui s'est formé en
1998 pendant une éruption longue de plus
de six mois
et c'est cool et de plusieurs millions
de mètres cubes de lave sont aussi à
l'origine du cratère katia et maurice
krafft situé en contrebas du cap horn
impressionnant
cette randonnée l avantage qu'elle a
c'est que elle permet de découvrir
l'enclos fouqué en sortant un peu des
sentiers battus aujourd'hui beaucoup de
monde sur le sentier principal kimono
cratère dolomieu
mais là bas on était quasiment tout seul
donc ça permet vraiment de goûter à la
tranquillité des lieux
ça donne d'autres points de vue des
cratères qu'on veut pas forcément des
petits pitt ont déconné rupture qu'on va
pas forcément sur le sentier principal
et les piles avantage aussi c'est
qu'elle est plus facile là il ya
quasiment aucun dénivelé pas par là la
descente du pas de bellecombe
donc c'est aussi là c'est aussi
davantage avantages de cette balade on
reste quand même dans un environnement
assez hostile on a plus de 1000 mètres
d'altitude on a beau être dans une
région tropicale il peut faire très
froid surtout en hiver il faut vraiment
y aller on va respecter toutes les
consignes classique on a l'habitude une
randonnée est bien chaussé apporter de
l'eau en quantité suffisante de quoi
manger et puis de quoi s'habiller
vraiment en cas de nécessité